if you've been watching my channel for a  while or my podcast you may notice I  look slightly different it's because I  was sitting extremely close to the  camera and the focal length was at about  25 and now it's at 50 60 something like  that this is actually what I look like  in person I don't look like the fish  from Pinocchio I've been wondering what  was going on for about a year every time  I looked at a clip I was like something  was off with my nose not entirely sure  I've talked to my husband about it like  we need to fix this something's weird  with my camera I do like 12 other things  other than the podcast so it wasn't my  primary concern I was just kind of  avoiding looking at myself on video  anyway focal length was off this is me